- I'm sitting between, I think
the two most employed people
in NFL media.
Radio shows, TV shows—
- We're workin'.
- But I mean, what's it like
for both of you guys?
- Once you leave the game,
you realize
"All right, I gotta bust my ass
and work just as hard
in my new craft."
So, like, every opportunity
is like me being a rookie again
and when I was a rookie
I walked in
to the Minnesota Vikings
and I'm seein' Daunte Culpepper
in a Theismann fur
and I'm seein' Randy Moss
swagged out with a baggy suit
and I'm like,
"Damn, this is the NFL."
These dudes pullin' up in
Bentleys with spinners on it.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like—
- In Minnesota.
- "I'm a baby. I'm a baby
and I gotta work."
Not only to make a name
for myself
but to, like,
get these guys' attention
and that was my goal,
to get the greats' attention.
So, like, what we do now
is if we gotta work one
two, three, four jobs, we want
to get attentions of the masses
cuz we're still workin'.
- I do wanna jump off
of something you said
a few minutes ago.
- Oh, Randy Moss?
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say, you
experienced young Randy Moss.
- Right.
- You experienced old Randy Moss.
- The first time
I met Randy Moss,
I knew immediately that
if I got an "attaboy" pat
on the back from him
I've arrived as a wide receiver.
But I went about it
the wrong way
because I was tryin'
to get his attention
like a thirsty dude
at the end of the night.
Like, I was like, "All right,
as soon as I hit him
with this icebreaker,
we're gonna be
best friends forever, man."
- [Laughing]
And I remember one day, I was
getting ready for practice
and I think
it was Jermaine Dupri.
He had a music video, and he's
wearin' the Marshall 88 jersey.
So I'm like in my little
dorm room at training camp.
I was like, "This is it, man."
And I remember,
I was doing conditioning
and I'm standing next to him,
and I'm literally
like, gassin' myself
up like a dude
about to walk across the bar
and ask a girl for their number.
I was like, "All right, man.
Come on.
Don't blow it, don't blow it."
And I was like, "Hey, uh, Randy, um."
Voice was crackin'.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what was goin' on.
I'm a grown man.
And I was like, "Did you see
the Jermaine Dupri video?
He had your jersey on, man."
And he's runnin' next to me.
He looks at me
and he just keeps on runnin'.
I was crushed!
- Ohhh!
- I was like, "Ugh."
Listen, I wrote a girl a note,
"Do you like me, yes or no?"
in the fifth grade,
and she crumpled it up
and threw it at my face.
- Oh, man.
- Randy Moss hurt me more.
Like, my feelings were crushed,
and I was like
"Damn, I blew it."
And then what's crazy is, like,
once I started makin' plays
like, that's when he came in
and was like, "All right."
Like, "I know you love the game
and I know you're one
of the good ones."
- It's funny, I think,
to hear him say that
because I don't think people
always realize
that football players
can also be fanboys.
First time Randy Moss
came on the plane
I was Row 27 by the window,
and he said, "Can I sit here?"
I was like [stuttering]
"Yeah, sure, sure.
You can sit here."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And, I mean,
that's the way I felt
but like Nate's sayin', too
the one thing I learned from him
in a hurry
is his perspective
on the game was, like, amazing.
He could almost see the game
almost like a quarterback.
- Yeah.
- He understood offense
and defense, and, you know
he understood
when this play was stupid
and he wasn't gonna
tell the coach
"That's a stupid play, Simms,"
you know, whatever it was.
- Yeah.
- I mean, and I just, I really
enjoyed being around him.
- Calvin is the forgotten guy.
- Yeah.
- If I'm creating a player
in "Madden"
he's 6'5" running a 4.3,
and his name is Calvin Johnson.
- Yeah.
- But he's never mentioned
in the "Jerry Rice, T.O.,
Randy Moss" top three.
But I would argue
he is physically as gifted
as any of them, if not more.
- No question.
I mean, it's the same individual
that broke Jerry Rice's
single-season record.
- Yeah.
And I watched him do it.
- Right.
- I watched games where
he would put up a buck 90
and we go to the meeting,
and after a loss
Shawn Jefferson,
who's a former player
wide receiver—he was
our wide receivers coach
He'd say, "Calvin, I need you to do more."
- [Laughing]
And, you know, I'm thinkin'
like, "Damn, what you want?
The dude go for 250?"
- Seriously.
- Yeah.
- And Calvin wouldn't
say anything.
He was quiet.
You know, his mother, a doctor.
Dad, he worked on
the railroad,
so he had this blend
of blue-collar and high IQ
and that was his approach
to life
and he would just nod his head
and say, "All right, Coach."
Next game, go put up 300.
Now, Randy was just pure speed
encapsulated.
If they put shoulder pads
and cleats on Usain Bolt
and he was actually a good
football player that can catch
and track the ball like no
other, it would be Randy Moss.
- Yeah.
- And Randy Moss had the greatest
late hands ever.
Even though coaches say, "Don't
panic, remember your cues
don't give anything away,"
like, we panic.
Like, we don't remember our
cues, and we give everything away.
Like, when the ball's
in the air
you start hearing your own
breath, and you go from—
[Panting]
And if you're
a really good DB
I know it's a small detail
but you can hear
a guy breathing hard
and then you see his eyes
go from here to here—
- Yes.
- And that right there is a cue
that something's coming.
- Right.
- Randy would, like, look
and the ball would be comin',
and his face doesn't move
his hands doesn't move,
his breath doesn't move
and then right when it gets
to him, he's like—
Velcro.
Like, that's something
that you might not see ever.
- No.
- I don't think so.
- And that's not something you coach.
It's something that God said
"Hey, Randy, I got
a little extra for you."
- Right. You the man.
- That was awesome.
- Nate Burleson's the man.
- He is the man.